seguimos analizando las varias aristas
de este conflicto y por supuesto está ya
conmigo en el estudio mar romero sala
marc crece el miedo a que rusia haga el
uso de su armamento nuclear que sabemos
de esta posibilidad más buenos días pues
por supuesto es imposible saber que
tiene vladimir putin o el kremlin en la
cabeza pero lo que sabemos con certeza
es lo que dijo hace unos días que era
que se ponían en la alerta a las fuerzas
de disuasión del ejército ruso eso
incluye varios armamentos entre ellos el
armamento nuclear
desde el kremlin se ha dicho que no hay
ningún tipo de amenaza nuclear en curso
pero claramente han logrado que estemos
hablando de ello y que estemos
explicando entonces vamos a morder ese
anzuelo y vamos a explicar que tiene que
pasar para que rusia lance un ataque
nuclear antes que nada tenemos que
recordar que el gobierno ruso estableció
en 2020 cuatro causales en las que
podría lanzar un ataque nuclear primero
que tengan información confiable sobre
el lanzamiento de misiles contra rusia o
sus aliados también el uso de armas de
armas nucleares por supuesto contra el
territorio ruso o el de sus aliados
pero que se ataquen infraestructuras
claves que minarán la capacidad nuclear
de rusia y cuarto y último el uso de
armas convencionales que citamos
textualmente pudieran poner en jaque la
misma existencia del estado ruso estas
son las cuatro condiciones que tiene
rusia para usarlas y pues creo que
podemos convenir que actualmente no
estamos en ninguno de ellos
marc y también como lo decías antes como
saberlo pues imposible porque además
recordemos que al inicio esta invasión
rusia siempre dijo que no iba a invadir
y mira lo que está pasando pero bueno en
caso de que rusia considere de que si
cumple alguno de estos cuatro casos que
acabas muy bien explicar qué sucede pues
llanamente el kremlin se considera
considera que el presidente ruso es el
único que puede ordenar este tipo de
ataque y para eso de hecho al lado de
vladimir putin en este caso siempre se
transporta un maletín conocido como
cheques desde ese maletín vladimir putin
se puede comunicar con los jefes
militares con el centro de control
militar y desde ese centro de control
militar se autorizarían los códigos de
lanzamiento a comandantes individuales
de algunas armas nucleares o bien se
podría iniciar el lanzamiento de algunos
misiles de tierra directamente sin tener
que pasar por estos mandos intermedios
es interesante recordar que lo cierto es
que eeuu también tiene otro maletín
llamado fútbol que también está en
presencia del presidente en todo momento
y que contiene códigos e información
también para dar órdenes nucleares
igualmente en ambos casos no son
maletines que carguen ningún botón rojo
que puedan apretar y directamente lanzar
sino sobre todo son a sistemas seguros
de comunicación para éste para este
motivo concreto marc actualmente
entonces en el mundo cuanto armamento
nuclear existe es muy difícil de saber
son estimaciones sobre todo el según
cifras de la federación de científicos
americanos vemos que rusia es el país
sigue siendo el país con más armamento
nuclear alrededor de 6 mil cabezas
nucleares los sigue eeuu con 5.400 y
entre los dos reúnen prácticamente el
90% de todo el arsenal nuclear mundial
eso no quiere decir que todos estos
estas cabezas nucleares estén
desplegadas sólo alrededor de 1600 mil
700 cabezas cada país del resto están
almacena es decir no están listos para
usarse inmediatamente vemos que china
francia reino unido también tienen
arsenal nuclear pero nada comparable y
aunque de manera un poco más velada y
mucho menos transparente se sabe que
pakistán india israel y corea del norte
también tienen algo de armamento
impactante y como el ser humano cree
estas armas para la destrucción masiva
de todos y para que para que objetivo
realmente no deberíamos preguntarnos
dios bueno mar qué ha pasado con los
tratados de desarme nuclear
a propósito esto por supuesto el
consenso desde hace años ha sido que se
tiene que desarmar no desarmar nuclear
mente y rusia y eeuu se han intentado
poner de acuerdo con este fin
actualmente hay un tratado vigente del
tratado new start y es vigente hasta
febrero de
2026 se prorrogó por cinco años
recientemente ante acuerdos de
transparencia inspecciones periódicas
sobre todo lo que se hace es limitar el
armamento los dos países sólo pueden
tener
1.550 cabezas nucleares desplegadas
recordemos que las cabezas son el arma
en sí y luego eso se lanza desde misiles
o submarinos cuyo número también está
limitado por este tratado consecuencias
mar por supuesto vamos a y el uso estas
armas nucleares es simple y llanamente
son centenares de miles de muertes raúl
se calcula que con sólo una cabeza
también podría haber más de un millón de
heridos y una destrucción considerable
en unos 900 kilómetros cuadrados esto
solo con una cabeza hay más de 10.000 en
todo el mundo la cantidad de daño que se
puede hacer con esto es totalmente
inimaginable lo que es más preocupante
sin embargo es que hay una cierta
narrativa de nostalgia en ucrania que
recordemos que era el tercer país con
más armamento nuclear justo cuando se
desintegró la unión soviética en 1994
ucrania decidió entregar sus armas a
rusia a cambio de que eeuu rusia y reino
unido- protegieran y respetaran su
soberanía y su integridad territorial
entonces qué pasa ahora 30 años después
rusia está violando este pacto está no
está respetando claramente las fronteras
ni la soberanía una craneana que mensaje
lanzamos al mundo estamos volviendo en
un momento en el que tener armas
nucleares hubiera valido la pena
deberíamos estar andando en la dirección
contraria hablar de eso conocida triste
es amar pensando lo destructivo que
somos nosotros en seres humanos además
también las consecuencias mira todo lo
que estamos haciendo y nos arrojan armas
nucleares con el planeta con nuestro
comportamiento y la inutilidad total
porque al final las armas nucleares son
las únicas que en verdad se tienen pero
no se pueden usar o sea prácticamente no
se pueden usar pero seguimos analizando
este tema marc con nuestra segunda mitad
al día